today I am going to teach you how to
play my favorite game massively
multiplayer thumb-wrestling it's the
only game in the world that I know of
that allows you the player the
opportunity to experience 10 positive
emotions in 60 seconds or less this is
true so if you play this game with me
today for just one single minute you
will get to feel joy relief love
surprise pride curiosity excitement all
in wonder contentment and creativity all
in the span of one minute so it sounds
pretty good right now you're willing to
play I'm in order to teach you this game
I'm gonna need some volunteers to come
up on stage really quickly we're gonna
do a little hands-on demo while they're
coming up I should let you know this
game was invented ten years ago by an
artist collective in Austria named
monochrome so thank you Monica
okay so most people are familiar with
traditional two-person thumb-wrestling
sunny let's just remind them one two
three four I declare a thumb war and we
wrestle and of course honeybees me
because she's the best now I the first
thing about massively multiplayer
thumb-wrestling we're the gamer
generation there are a billion gamers on
the planet now so we need more of a
challenge so the first thing we need is
more thumbs so Eric come on over so we
could get three thumbs together and
Peter could join us we could even have
four thumbs together and the way you win
is you're the first person to pin
someone else's thumb this is really
important you can't like wait while they
fight it out and then swoop in at the
last minute that is not how you win who
did that Eric did that so Eric would
have won he was the first person to pin
my thumb okay so that's the first rule
and we can see that three or four is
kind of the typical number of thumbs in
a node but I
if you feel ambitious you don't have to
hold back we can really go for it so you
can see up here okay now the only other
rule you need to remember is you know
game regeneration we like a challenge I
happen to notice you all have some
thumbs you're not using so I think we
should kind of get some more involved
and if we had just four people we would
do it just like this
and we would try and wrestle you know
both sums at the same time now perfect
now if we had more people in the room
instead of just wrestling in a closed
node we might reach out and try and grab
some other people and in fact that's
what we're gonna do right now we're
gonna try and get all something like I
don't know 1,500 thumbs in this room
connected in a single nodes so and we
have to connect both levels so if you're
up there you're gonna be reaching down
and reaching up now before we get
started this is great you're excited to
play before we get started can I have
the slides back up here really quick
because if you get good at this game I
want you to know there are some advanced
levels so this is the the kind of simple
level right but there are advanced
configuration this is called the death
star configuration any Star Wars fans
and this one's called The Mobius strip
any science geeks you get that one this
is the hardest level this is the extreme
so we'll stick with the normal one for
now and I'm gonna give you 30 seconds
every thumb into the node connect the
upper in the lower level for you guys go
on down there 30 seconds into the
network make the node stand up it's
easier if you stand up everybody up up
up up up stand up my friends all right
don't start wrestling yet if you have a
free thumb wave it around make sure it
gets connected okay we need to do a
last-minute thumb check if you have a
free thumb wave it around to make sure
grab that some you reach behind you
there you go any other thumbs okay on
the count of three you're gonna go try
to keep track grab grab grab it okay one
two three go
did you win you got it you got it
excellent well done thank you thank you
very much
all right while you are basking in the
glow of having won your first massive
leuthar mice again let's do a quick
recap on the positive emotion so
curiosity I said massively multiplayer
thumb-wrestling you were like what the
hell is she talking about so I provoked
a little curiosity creativity took
creativity to solve the problem of
getting all the thumbs into lunar
reaching around and I'm reaching up so
use creativity that was great
how about surprised the actual feeling
of trying to wrestle to thumbs it once
is pretty surprising you heard that
sound go up in the room we had
excitement as you started to wrestle
maybe you're starting to win or this
person's like really into it so you kind
of get it get the excitement going we
have relief you got to stand up you've
been sitting for a while see the
physical relief came to shake it out we
had joy did you guys you were laughing
smiling look at your faces this room is
full of joy we had some contentment I
didn't see anybody sending text messages
or checking the email while we were
playing you're totally content to be
playing the most important three
emotions all in wonder we had everybody
connected physically for a minute when
was the last time you were at Teddy you
got to connect physically with every
single person in the room that is truly
awesome and wondrous and speaking of
physical connection you guys know I love
the the hormone oxytocin you release
oxytocin you feel bonded to everyone in
the room you guys know that the best way
to release oxytocin quickly is to hold
someone else's hand for at least six
seconds you guys were all holding hands
for way more than six seconds so we are
all now biochemically primed to love
each other that is great and the last
emotion of pride how many people are
like you just like me just admit it you
lost both your thumbs it just was didn't
work out for you that's okay because you
learned a new skill today you learned
from scratch a game you never knew
before now you know how to play it you
can teach other people so
congratulations how many of you want
just one thumb all right I very good
news for you according to the Official
Rules a massively multiplayer
thumb-wrestling
this makes you a grand master of the
game because there aren't that many
people who know how to play we have to
kind of accelerate the program more than
like a game like chess
so congratulations grandmasters win one
thumb once you argue
becoming a master um did anybody win
both their thumbs yes awesome
okay get ready to update your Twitter or
Facebook status you guys according to
the rules are legendary grandmasters so
congratulations I will just leave you
with this tip if you want to play again
the best way to become a legendary
Grandmaster you got you two nodes going
on pick off the one that looks easiest
or not paying attention they look kind
of weak focus on that one and do
something crazy with this arm as soon as
you win suddenly stop everybody just
throwing off you go in for the kill
that's like become a legendary
Grandmaster vastly multiplayer
thumb-wrestling thank you for letting me
teach you my favorite game
[Applause]